hi anna hi steve now you were just
telling me that you have uh discovered
something new yeah that you enjoy doing
yeah and what is that
in the beginning i love link but i
really really love
because now with the new feature
we can import every youtube video from
from youtube so for me it's amazing
because i can learn about marketing
because there are a lot of stuff in
youtube about marketing so i can improve
my vocab my fluency in specific in
digital marketing
so everything and now i i
i
look in youtube first import to
you but you get the the text how do you
get the text yeah it's so easy yes it's
one click yes you need just put the
import and
this extension yeah
click and in one click import to to link
so it imports the audio yeah
the text in other words the transcript
yes
and the video yeah it's amazing yeah so
then you can just be if you have the
time you watch the video yeah if you
want to listen to it on the bus just
listen yeah if you want to read through
it and say words and phrases you have
the textbook because
one thing that helped a lot for
learn english or whatever any any
language is listening in youtube but the
nice thing you can do in link is that
you can um
say for your words right
you your revolution about the all the
keyword the words
so i think this is for me it's amazing
also i i i'm watching friends right so
yeah yeah so now import a small
eclipse yes like 50 50 for 10 minutes
put in link and repeat and
so you can have quite a variety of
content you can have stuff that relates
to your work yes the digital marketing
yeah and yet you can also do uh friends
yeah tv programs yeah
that's good
uh i think
i don't i remember i tried doing it for
arabic and i couldn't find any videos on
youtube
that had the arabic because it has to
have the closed captioning it has to
have the subtitles yeah yeah so i didn't
find any for arabic so there might be
some languages where it doesn't work so
for english it's amazing i think yeah
there's lots but i would think for
french and spanish and german and
russian and chinese korean yeah i think
there's lots yeah because
i remember in the beginning other thing
you
say to me was that one thing that told
me
was that
um it's very important learn
english or
the language with content you love
so now youtube have
all continued unlimited so really you
want to
learn with continued love
and you know what's so interesting is
when we when i was at school learning
like french in school long long time ago
of course you have one little book
that's it that's all the content that
you can access right yeah whereas
nowadays the content is unlimited yeah
some people like to learn from songs so
again if you find a song
that you you love this song in german or
chinese or whatever and there's a
youtube video which there often is you
can just bring it in and study that on
the link so yeah that's good yeah it's
really nice i love it good okay well
that suggestion then for all of you out
there yeah okay
oh and we mustn't yeah you forgot i
forgot i forgot so uh it's the holiday
season yeah
and so i think you can't give a nicer
gift to your friends and relatives and
family members than the gift of language
a gift of
three six and twelve twelve month
membership in lincoln yeah
[Music]
is
okay
see you bye
[Music]
you